The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
We have been talking about the
properties of transition metal
complexes, coordination
complexes, in the context of a
simple crystal field theory
model.
And I just wanted to make
reference at the beginning,
today, to state diagrams.
And, in the context of
octahedral complexes,
you saw that an array of six
ligands surrounding a central
metal ion would lead to a t two
g and what we are
calling an eg star
manifold of orbitals on the
metal in which we can populate
with the number of d electrons
that we have present.
And the graph that I am making
here is related to the idea that
for a system with only a single
electron, so this could be,
for example,
titanium OH two six times three
plus.
This is a d one system.
And it can go from a ground
state configuration of t two g
one eg star zero.
And then, upon absorption of
light, it can be promoted from
the ground state,
represented here,
into the excited state.
And the excited state has the
configuration t two g zero eg
star one,
showing that that electron has
been promoted through absorption
of a photon.
And this gap here between t(2g)
and eg star,
of course, is our delta O
value.
And the axis on the bottom,
here, is ligand field strength.
This is supposed to tell you
that different ligands give rise
to different values of delta O
accounting for the fact that
this d one titanium
three ion in a field
of water molecules has one
color, whereas,
if you, in fact, look at
Ti Cl six three minus,
you will be able to tell that
that also is a titanium three
plus or d one
system.
But they do not have the same
color.
And the one absorption band
that you find in the visible
part of the spectrum that
corresponds to promotion of an
electron from t two g
into eg star is just
moving around a little bit in
energy because these ligands
behave differently with respect
to what we call their ligand
field strength that they exert,
that leads to a particular
energy gap between t(2g) and
e(g)*.
I will get into this a little
bit further in the moment,
but the point here is that d
one or d nine
are special electron counts.
And the reason that they are
special is that these have a
single absorption peak due to
what we call d-d transitions.
They have a single d-d
transition.
And that means there is a
ground state and then just one
excited state that the system
can be promoted to in the
presence of impinging photons of
the right energy.
And what happens is that if you
have more d electrons than just
one, or d nine is
special because we treat that
using a whole formalism,
like there is just one electron
missing from a complete
manifold, a completely full d
shell minus one.
With d^n systems,
for example,
d two is much more
complex.
And this is beyond the scope of
5.112, but it is something that
they are treating in 5.04,
for example.
If you go on in organic
chemistry, you will learn how
come different states can arise,
multiple states arise when you
have more than just a one
electron picture.
For example,
if you have a vanadium three
plus ion,
there are three bands observed.
And so the simple picture that
you have, just a t(2g) level and
an e(g) level is correct and
maps onto the picture of the
electronic states that are
available, as long as we are
just talking about a one
electron picture.
With more electrons in play,
depending on just which of the
orbitals they go into,
they will have inter-electron
repulsion terms that come into
play and give rise to more
excited states.
Here, with three bands being
observed in the visible,
that means there are three
possible transitions and three
possible excited states that can
be accessed.
So it is a very complicated
picture.
And so we are going to be,
for the purposes of this,
focusing on the one electron
picture.
But I just wanted you to be
aware that it does get a lot
more complex as soon as you go
to many electron systems.
Now, let's talk just briefly
about pairing energy.
In the case of 3d system,
we typically find that the
pairing energy is around 15
to 18,000 reciprocal
centimeters, the typical energy
unit given for pairing energy.
But then if we go to heavier
transition elements,
to the 4d or the 5d elements,
then typically the pairing
energy is about 8,000 to 12
reciprocal centimeters.
And what that says is that it
is easier to pair up electrons
in 4d or 5d orbitals than it is
to put two electrons in the same
3d orbital.
And the reason for that is just
what the radial extension is of
these orbitals.
In effect, these orbitals are
larger than the 3d orbitals.
And it means that if you put
two electrons into the same 4d
or 5d orbital,
much of the time they can stay
farther apart from each other
than if they are in a 3d
orbital.
And so this has the practical
consequence that 4d and 5d
systems often are low spin.
And so this high spin/low spin
issue that we talked about last
time is mostly focused on
complexes of the 3d ions.
So then we are talking about
titanium, vanadium,
chromium, etc.
And, if we come over here,
we can ask, what is the effect
of charge on delta O?
This is all pointing back to
the state diagram that I showed
you over there in this kind of
sliding scale,
where you can change things
like just what type of metal ion
you have, 3d,
4d, or 5d.
Or you can change the nature of
the ligands.
Or you can even change the
charge on the metal as a way of
changing delta O.
And so we can look at,
for example,
chromium hexaaquo two plus
versus chromium
hexaaquo three plus.
The first is a d four ion.
And then, the second is a d
three ion.
You should practice going from
a formula into the d^n count.
And then we can look at what
delta O does.
This is roughly 14,000 wave
numbers.
And then, when we oxidize from
2+ to 3+, higher charge on the
central metal,
delta O shoots up to about
approximately 17,000.
And this is in reciprocal
centimeters.
We see that putting a higher
charge on the metal center leads
to a larger value of delta O.
And that is also true if we
look at some other metal systems
along these lines.
For example,
there are just a number of
different metals for which the
hexaaquo systems can be
generated in both the 2+ and the
3+ state of charge.
And here, we go from about
12,000 and then oxidize,
and we get up to about 18,000,
so even a larger increase in
the value of delta O on going
from the 2+ to the 3+ oxidation
state of the metal.
And then in the notes you will
find that I put in another
example that behaves similarly
based on cobalt.
If you go from cobalt two to
cobalt three hexaaquo,
you go from about 9,000 up to
18,000 reciprocal centimeters.
So almost doubling the value of
delta O by removing one electron
from the system.
What is going on here is that
the greater charge --
-- pulls the ligands in closer
to the metal.
And if the ligands are in
closer to the metal,
then what that ends up saying
is you will see in a moment
because we are going to get to
the MO picture for octahedral
coordination complexes,
is that putting electrons in e
g star becomes more
difficult.
Delta O is larger.
The ligands come in closer,
and that is effectively
shrinking that value of r when
we talked about our spherical
coordinates as applied to the
angular parts of the d-orbital
wavefunctions and looking at
that.
So we are changing r.
The ligands are coming in
closer to the more positively
charged metal ion in that case.
And then we can also look at
the effect of changing the
ligand.
In the system on the left,
we were looking at pairs of
metal complexes with the same
ligand and changing the charge.
And now we are just going to
say, what happens if you change
the ligand?
And this will be a series of
vanadium complexes.
We have five of them.
We have the vanadium hexaaquo.
This one is 3+.
We have the vanadium with six
urea molecules.
And this is also 3+.
We have vanadium hexafluoride
three minus.
And these are all vanadium in
the +3 oxidation state.
Then we have vanadium
hexachloride three minus,
and down here the fifth one
will be vanadium with six
cyanide ligands and three minus.
So these are all d two
systems with vanadium in the +3
oxidation state.
And here, we are going from
18,000 reciprocal centimeters to
the hexafluoride.
And we drop down to 16,000.
And this is all approximate.
And six urea on vanadium,
we go up to about 17,0000.
And then, with the
hexachloride,
we are down to about a delta O
of 12,000 reciprocal
centimeters.
And then we put cyanides on,
and delta O pops up to about
23,000 wave numbers.
So this is the same metal ion
but in five different ligand
environments.
It has five very different
values of delta O.
And from this,
we can derive a spectrochemical
series --
-- for organizing ligands with
respect to the magnitude of
delta O that they exert for a
given metal ion.
And this one just gives us a
series that contains five
ligands.
But, as you can imagine,
many more ligands than just
these five simple ligands have
been looked at with a variety of
different metal ions to make a
pretty big overall comprehensive
spectrochemical series that sort
of allows you to pick out which
ligand you want when you are
interested in generating a
particular value of delta O.
And here what you see is that
the weakest one is chloride.
We have chloride.
And then next was fluoride.
And then next was urea followed
by water.
And then the strongest in this
small series of five was
cyanide.
And when we try to understand
the order that these different
ligands appear in,
in the spectrochemical series,
we are going to find out,
as we study the properties of
the molecular orbitals of these
systems, that cyanide is a pi
acid.
And that down here,
chloride is a pi donor.
And in the middle,
you have systems like water
which is more or less sigma
only.
So we can understand where
specific ligands appear in the
spectrochemical series on the
basis of their orbital
considerations.
And that will be the focus of
the next part of the lecture.
I would like to talk a little
bit about sigma-only ligands.
The process in which we are now
about to engage is very similar
to that which we used in class
for generating the molecular
orbital energy level diagram for
the BH three molecule.
In that case we had a central
boron and three hydrogens around
it, and we made some hydrogen
linear combinations.
And we saw how they would
interact with the atomic
orbitals of the boron.
And now we are going to do the
same thing, except we have a lot
more orbitals in the system as a
whole, so we are approximating
some of them.
Here is a typical sigma-only
ligand, NH three.
And for NH three,
we have a lone pair on the
nitrogen here.
And I am drawing it in very
simplified fashion,
as you will no doubt
appreciate.
There is our lone pair.
And, when this points directly
at the metal,
the lone pair can make a sigma
bond to the metal.
I think you will appreciate
that if we have a metal out here
such that this lone pair of
electrons is directed right at
the metal, then that results in
a cylindrically symmetric lone
pair about that metal-nitrogen
internuclear axis.
And so that would be a
sigma-type of interaction.
So this is called a sigma-only
ligand.
And other ligands,
like cyanide or like chloride,
we are going to have to add in
pi effects, but this is the
simple sigma-only case.
And so if you take a molecule
such as this cobalt hexamine two
plus, --
-- or, actually,
let's say three plus for
simplicity here.
Cobalt three plus.
And we have these NH three
ligands at each of the
six positions.
And, in each case,
the orientation of the
hydrogens on these nitrogens is
such as to promote a sigma
directing effect of that lone
pair toward the metal.
And so that lone pair of
electrons on the nitrogen for
each of these ammonia ligands
directed right at the metal is
providing this repulsion that
pumps e(g) up in energy.
And you will see that,
hopefully, very clearly now.
And let me point out that this
orbital, here,
that I am focusing on is the
HOMO of NH three.
What we are doing is saying you
have a central metal ion and
then you have six ammonia
ligands pointing at it,
each of them pointing their
HOMO at the metal,
their highest occupied
molecular orbital.
What does that do?
What kinds of bonds arise as a
consequence of that between the
metal ion and these six ammonia
molecules?
And so we will now see what
that is on the basis of some of
the linear combinations that we
can generate between the six
HOMOs of the NH three's in this
kind of a geometry.
I will do the first one over
here.
I would like to use a different
color for that.
I am going to use my blue.
All right.
I am going to draw for you some
linear combinations of ammonia
lone pairs.
These are simplistically
representing the homo of each NH
three directed at the
metal.
That one has the symmetry of a
cobalt s orbital.
It has the same sign
everywhere.
And then, we are going to see
that you can draw three of
these.
And I will draw them all right
here --
-- in pairs.
And this one has the symmetry
of a cobalt pz atomic orbital.
You see it has positive up
there.
And down here,
we are taking this to be x,
this to be y,
and this to be z for each of
our diagrams,
so that the phase properties of
this combination is that of pz.
This one is like px.
This one is like py.
And the only reason we have to
take these linear combinations
is because we have multiple
equivalent ammonia molecules in
this problem.
And then, we have two more that
are of interest to us.
One of these will have a couple
of big lobes located on z,
pointed at the metal and then
four small lobes,
each with negative phase.
I will shade them to indicate
that negative phase.
And that one will have the same
phase properties as a cobalt d z
squared orbital.
Plus above, plus below.
And then, to match up with the
torus in the center of d z
squared in the
x,y-plane, the negative phase
shown there.
And then, finally,
over here we have one where all
four contributions to this one
are in the x,y-plane,
along the x and y axes and with
shading as shown there.
And that is of the same
symmetry as our d x squared
minus y squared
orbital.
Having written down this set of
six linear combinations that we
can generate from our six
ammonia HOMOs,
we are done because the cobalt
has atomic orbitals of these
symmetries.
We can now use these to make
bonds between the ammonia
molecules and the cobalt.
And we can use them to make
corresponding antibonds.
Here is the MO diagram for the
sigma-only case.
What we have is an energy level
diagram that will represent the
interaction of these linear
combinations with the metal
valance orbitals.
And so I am going to draw the
metal valance orbitals over here
as follows.
We have, on the metal,
the 3d, the 4s,
and the 4p.
And some of you will notice
that this ordering of energies
is a little different than what
you saw when you just built up
atomic configurations,
because what I have drawn here
is the set of five 3d atomic
orbitals is down lower in energy
than the cobalt 4s and lower in
energy, that is,
even still, than the cobalt 4p.
This is our cobalt atom here.
And the reason this energy
ordering for the valance
orbitals is difference is
because we have an ionized
cobalt.
And the energies change around
when you remove an electron from
the system as compared to the
neutral atom.
But one thing that will help
you remember this ordering of
energy levels is that it goes in
the order of the principle
quantum number,
which kind of does make a
little sense.
In fact, these energies switch
around, depending on which of
the metals you are talking
about.
But generally 3d and 4s,
or alternatively 4d and 5s,
are pretty close in energy to
each other, depending on the ion
that you are talking about.
And then 4p is usually
energetically a bit separated
from that.
And then the thing that makes
us focus our attention so
strongly on the d orbitals is
that those are the ones closest
in energy to the ligand orbitals
that can interact with them.
And so let me draw over here a
bar that represents the six LCs
of NH three HOMOs.
In essence, this represents
these six drawings that I drew
over here, linear combinations
that have the right symmetry to
interact with certain of valance
orbitals on the cobalt,
here on the left.
And what we will find is that--
And we will start with the 3d,
since that is what we are going
to be principally interested in
here.
We come over and find that
three of the d orbitals do not
match any of these because these
NH three HOMOs all lie
in nodal surfaces of them.
And that will be,
of course, our t(2g) set.
Those have the same energy as
in the ion itself.
They come straight over and
don't get involved in bonding or
antibonding interactions.
These are nonbonding.
That is t(2g).
And then, what we find is that
of these six linear
combinations,
two of them,
shown right here,
have the correct phase
properties to make bonding and
antibonding combinations by
interacting with d z squared
and d x squared minus
y squared.
We show that down here.
Here is a bonding combination.
This has e(g) symmetry,
and it represents the formation
of two bonds between the metal
and the ligands.
And, of course,
we also make an antibonding
combination of the same
symmetry.
This should just remind you of
the hydrogen H two
molecule molecular orbital
problem built into this much
larger structure.
And this one,
this antibonding case is e g
star.
And let's just quickly look at
them.
Here, what we have is a d z
squared orbital with
its torus interacting in an
out-of-phase manner with these
ammonia lone pairs.
That creates antibonding
character here and here,
making this a high-energy
orbital.
And then, we have antibonding
character, too,
in between each of the ammonias
located on the x,y-plane and the
torus of the d z squared.
So that is one of our two e g
star orbitals.
And over here,
we have our d x squared minus y
squared orbital
making antibonding interactions
with this other linear
combination, as shown here,
such that we get antibonding
all the way around.
That is e g star.
That is the reason why the e(g)
set, derived from our set of d
orbitals, is marked with an
asterisk.
It is antibonding with respect
to these bonds.
If you start to populate e(g)*
with electrons,
as you will do in certain cases
that are high-spin,
for example,
those electrons that go into
e(g)*, if you reflect back on
the way that we calculate bond
order, they go in there and
weaken these two metal ligand
bonds.
And these two bonds look just
identical to the ones I drew
here for e(g)*,
just reversing the phase and
making them bonding everywhere.
Let's just look at those.
Here, we have d z squared
making a nice bonding
combination.
It is interacting in an
in-phase manner with that linear
combination, so we have bonding
both in the x,y-plane and
strongly along the z-axis.
That is one of these two bonds.
And then over here,
we will have x squared minus y
squared,
making bonds also --
-- like that.
Down here, this is bonding,
and this is antibonding.
Now, that is not the entire
diagram.
One runs out of space pretty
quickly on these
horizontally-oriented boards for
putting together tall MO
diagrams, but there were six LCs
over here.
And you will see that there
will be another one that makes a
bond with the 4s orbital.
And so, accordingly,
the 4s orbital comes up here.
There will be an antibond
derived from 4s.
There will be also a set of
three that are antibonding
derived from interaction of 4p
with the other ones,
here.
And there is a big energy
mismatch between 4p and these,
so we will draw these as the
least stabilized of the set.
But now, what you can see down
here is that we have found a way
to form six bonds,
six pairs of electrons,
each coming from the highest
occupied molecular orbital of
the six ammonia molecules.
We have formed six bonds using
these valance orbitals of the
metal.
And how many more electrons do
we have to put into the diagram?
We have six because this,
in the case of our cobalt (NH
three) six three plus --
This is Group 9.
Minus three for the 3+ charge.
All the ammonia ligands are
neutral, equals six.
So this is a d six case.
The orbitals here that we
called t(2g) and e g star
can now take up six
more electrons.
And I am drawing them in here
with the assumption that this is
a low-spin case.
And that is reasonable based on
the 3+ charge of this ion.
We have already discussed the
effective charge.
It draws the ligands in.
It tends to increase the value
of delta O, as we have seen.
And so this is how I would
populate that diagram,
with the 6d electrons going
into the nonbonding t(2g)
constituting the highest
occupied molecular orbital of
this system.
And then, stabilize the lone
pairs.
Down here what is really going
on, you can think about these
six ammonia molecules acting
simultaneously as six Lewis
bases to a metal that has enough
empty orbitals to accept six
lone pair donations to that same
metal.
So it is a Lewis acid times
six.
And it is positively charged,
which of course tends to draw
electron density to it.
And that is our simplified
molecular orbital diagram for
the sigma-only case.
Now, there are a lot of other
interesting cases.
As you can see here from this
spectrochemical series where the
ligands in the middle are
basically sigma-only urea,
water.
But then at either end of the
spectrochemical series,
you get into systems where you
must take pi effects into
account.
And we will treat,
first, the case of a pi donor.
Remember that if we are talking
about a donor,
that means we are effectively
talking about a Lewis base.
And you have to ask yourself
the question in a system that
has a ligand that can make pi
bonds, are the orbitals on the
metal that have pi symmetry
filled, or are they empty?
And, similarly,
are the pi symmetry orbitals on
the ligand in question filled or
are they empty?
And, if you can get all that
right, you will really
understand what happens in terms
of attenuating t(2g) when you
add in pi effects.
We have seen that the e(g)
orbitals of a metal are the d z
squared and d x
squared minus y squared
that point along the
axes.
The xz, yz, and xy that point
between the axes have the
potential to make pi bonds with
ligands.
And so here is an example of a
type of ligand that can make pi
bonds to a metal.
This ligand is NH two minus.
And it can make both sigma and
pi bonds to a metal.
It is usually the case that if
a ligand is capable of making pi
bonds to a metal,
it is also capable of making
sigma bonds.
And so the pi effects are sort
of mapped onto the sigma
framework.
And so what we found over here
and here about the sigma only
case, that will also be true for
pi systems.
But then we are superposing on
that diagram the pi bonds that
can form in the system.
And the way that NH two minus
can make both sigma
and pi bonds with a metal is,
first of all,
it has a lone pair that is
directed at the metal,
like this.
For forming sigma contacts.
And, if you have six of these
around a metal,
the situation would be just the
same as what we derived over
here for the cobalt hexamine.
But this is a planar system.
The sum of the bond angles
around the nitrogen in systems
like this are 360 degrees
meaning that,
unlike ammonia itself,
which is a trigonal pyramid,
this is a planar system.
And so it has a lone pair
perpendicular to that plane.
I will draw it that way.
It is just a pure p-orbital,
perpendicular to the plane of
the substituents on that
nitrogen.
And the way that could make a
pi bond with the metal is
through simultaneous donation
above and below the plane of its
substituents on that nitrogen,
so that this ligand can
interact as a double Lewis base
with a metal if the metal has
appropriate orbitals available.
And so a situation in which you
might find this would be the
following.
An example of such a molecule,
this would be a neutral one.
And what you see is that the
planes of these NH two
units are lining up with the
coordinate xz,
yz, and xy Cartesian planes in
the molecule.
Since each of these ligands is
negatively charged and the
molecule is neutral,
the chromium is therefore in
the +6 oxidation state to
balance the six negative charges
on the amido ligands,
we call them.
This is amido.
And so this one,
in fact, is a d zero case.
And d zero is an
electron count that is pretty
typical for the formation of pi
bonds from ligands that can
donate into the metal center.
If you have d electrons present
in a system like this,
then you won't have the empty
d-orbitals on the metal that are
necessary to accept bonds formed
by lone pair donation of this
sort.
The system will become choked
up on itself with too many
electrons.
Let's see what those
perturbations will lead to for
our MO diagram.
I am going to focus in on
linear combinations of amide
lone pair orbitals that,
in fact, have the correct
symmetry to interact with our
t(2g) set, since that is our pi
set of orbitals from the d
manifold on the metal.
So let's look at this.
This would be d(yz).
And then, let me choose --
We can make a pi bond of this
sort using a linear combination
that I am mating up together
with the d(yz) orbital.
And while I have drawn here the
bonding counterpart there,
of course, will be an
antibonding counterpart for
that.
Let's draw the one that belongs
to d(xz).
And that will be the one up
top, here.
So what we have is pi bonding
happening here,
here, here, and here that
corresponds to pi lone paired
donation into that metal
orbital.
And then, finally,
we have one that involves the
d(xy).
And this would be with our
hydrogens up and down,
here and here.
Sorry.
Up and down in front and in
back like that,
so that we can make two pi
bonding interactions over here
with this.
There is pi bonding,
pi bonding, bonding,
bonding.
At this point,
we have gotten to where we can
recognize how there are three
linear combinations of the pi
lone pairs from these amido
ligands that will have the
correct symmetry to interact
with the t(2g) set from our
metal.
There are three more where you
would just flip one of the two
on each, and those would have
the correct symmetry to interact
with the px, py,
and pz orbitals on the metal.
I am not going to draw those
out since we are focusing on the
d part of our diagram at the
moment.
And what we will find then,
in the molecular orbital
diagram for a system of this
sort, is that our d manifold,
this is our 3d,
4s, 4p, is such that,
you remember previously t two g
came straight over.
And now, instead,
we are going to see that it
goes up in energy because what
t(2g) now is,
it still has a lot of d(xz),
d(yz) and d(xy).
But now, t two g has
acquired a pi star
character due to the fact that
we have these linear
combinations over here.
These are our pi LCs that we
drew over there that are of the
appropriate symmetry to interact
with d(xz), d(yz) and d(xy).
And, therefore,
these that are filled are
stabilized, come down here and
form a t two g set
that is bonding because those,
of course, are filled in,
NH two minus.
And, if the metal has an empty
t two g set,
you see that we do get three pi
bonds.
t two g now gives us
pi antibonds.
This is being mapped on the
sigma framework that is the same
as what we have right here for
the cobalt hexamine,
so that above t(2g) we will
have the e(g)*.
And will now recognize that
e(g) is sigma star
rather than pi star,
so it is more strongly
destabilized due to the greater
overlap considerations of
forming sigma bonds versus the
side to side overlap of pi
bonds.
And the key observation here is
that pi donors --
-- decrease the magnitude of
delta O by raising the energy of
t(2g), by making t(2g) pi* in
character.
Antibonding.
We can see, not only that t(2g)
should be raised up,
but that mapping that onto our
full sigma framework diagram,
delta O is shrinking.
We still have our six sigma
bonds between the NH two
ligands and the metal.
They are down here,
just not drawn.
It is the same as up here.
And now, we have three
additional pi bonds.
There are another three
additional pi bonds that you can
draw because we do have six of
these NH two minus
ligands.
And then, the corresponding
antibonding orbitals involve 4p.
And they are way up here
somewhere in energy and very
empty.
Since this was a d zero
case, what we have is that you
have we pairs of electrons on
six NH two minus's
that are down here in this
manifold of metal ligand sigma
and pi bonding.
And so we have 12 pairs of
electrons down here that
describe the sigma plus pi
bonding between the metal and
the ligands.
And then you come here to your
d manifold, these are empty
because this is a d zero
case, because I happened to
choose chromium in the six plus
oxidation here.
So it is a d zero case,
and we wouldn't have any
electrons to put in here.
But, under these circumstances,
in order to get color in a
system like this,
you would have to be promoting
an electron from down here from
these pi bonds probably into the
d manifold, for example.
And what we have seen here,
namely that pi donors decrease
delta O should give you a clue
as to what is going on with
chloride and fluoride.
Since those have small values
of delta O, they lie at a
position of weakness in the
spectrochemical series.
And in the converse,
that ligands like cyanide and
especially carbon monoxide are
very high in the spectrochemical
series because they are pi acid
ligands.
And this is something you will
be getting more information
about in recitation this week.
See you all on Wednesday.